>> Tucr:OOD ENING, AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKECARLSON
NIGHT."
LAST YEAR UEKNOWNST TO PRETTY
MUCH NOBOD AOMAN IN BOKLYN
STTED A TWITTER AOUNT THAT
WAS COMPRISED ALMT SOLY OF
DEOS OF LIBERS TKING ABOUT
THSELVES.
THE CCEPT IS VY SIME:
ND INTERESTINGAPE TT HAD
ALADY BEEN UOADE TO THE
INTERNET BY PEOP WHO MADE IT
D REPOSTHAT TAP
EDITING,O SPECIAL EFFTS,
VERY LITTLE ETORIAL CONTENT.THES
TYPES DESCRIBED IN THE OWN
WORDS WHAT THEY BELF,
UNFIERED.
ACCOUNT CALLEDTATED THAT
@LibfTikTok.MORE FOLWERSHAN THEF
WYOMING.
MOREHANHE NIGHTLY VIERSHIP
ON CNN.
SO ITAS QUITE SUCCESSL BY
THE QUESTION I WHY?
HE IS WHY: IT TURNS OUT AS
REPELLT AS ACADEMICIFESLE
BERALISM MAY SEEM T YOU AAN
OBSERV, THE REATY OF IT ASDESCRO
ACTUALLY BELIEVE THI STUFFS
EVEN WORSEHAN YOU EVEIMAGINED ID
DISGUSTING.
IT IS LIKE WATCHING MEONE EAT
ROADKILL: Y FL NAUSEOUS BUT
YO CAN'TURN AWAY.
KINDS OF TAPON THE INTERNET,
NCH OF SELFISTYLE VEOS
FROMHE PUBLICLY AVLABLE
CIAL MEDIA ACCOUNTS OFTEACHERST.
TH JUS FOUND PEOPLE WHO
ALREY POSTED.HERE IS WHATOUND.
>> HI,Y NE IA PRESCHOOL
TEACHE
WE RECENTLY STARTED WRING
PRONOUPINS AND THE KIDSET TO
PI A NEW PRONOUN PIN EVERY -SOML
ACHE
I E THEY-THEM PRONOSN THE
ISKAY.OOM.THEY DO NOT ALL GETT T
>> THOUGHTE BEING PY W
CRAZ BUT NOT OY THAT, TY
KNOW I AM GENDERLUID.
>> I'M GNG TO GIVE YOUY
EXPLANATIOBOUTHAT IT MEANSTO BE.
SO WHE BABIES ARE BOR THE
DOCTORS OK AT THEM A THEYMAKE AE
BABY IS AOY OR A GIRL.>> KIDS AR
UR ARE AWARE OTHEIRENDER
IDTITY EVEN IF TY D'T HAVE
A LANGUAGEOR EIGHT.
PRK THUGH THIRD GRA ARE
NOT ADY FOR SH TICSS
ENTRANCE PHOA.LIZEDOMOPHOBIA
>> Tucker: [UGHS]
THOSE ARE THE PEOE IN
ARGE O TENNG TO YOUSMAL
CHDREN'S MINDS WHILE Y ARE
AT WOR
W MAE YOU AGREE WH THE
VIS YOU JUST HRD,AYBE YOU
THINKOCTORS JUSTUESS THEEX
EITHER WAY, Y ARE AIGHT AS A
PARENT TO KNOWHATHESE PEOEARE T.
D YET BEFORE @LibsofTikT,
THERE S NOT AN EASY WAY T
FI OUTHAT THEYERE
TEACHING, THEYAD T TAK THE
TEACHER'S RD FOR IT.
TURNS OUT THE ARE AN AWF LOT
OF VIDEOS LIKES O TRE.
@LsofTTok FOUND A L OF
THEM
HE F EXAMPLES ONE FROM A
PRIVATE SCOL IN
WAINGTON, D.C.
[CHILDRE SINGING]
OKAY, SOET'SAY YOU ARE
PAYING $,000 A YEAR TO SEN
YO KIDS TO SOME OVERRATMEDIOCREE
DISTCT O COLBIA.
YOU THINK ERYTHING IS FE,
U PU UP @LibsofTiok ANDFIND OUTY
HAENING IN YOUR DS CL
CLASSROOM.
WHAT I WRO WITH THAT?
THISS JRNALISM.
NO NEWS ORGANATIO I AMERICA
HAS DONE MORE  REVEAL THE --
THEN @LibsofTiok.
WE AED A NUMBER OFIDEOS ON
OUR SHOW.
R MORETRAIT FOR
"THE NEW YORTIME OR
"WASHINGTON ST"ECAUSE IT WAS
NOT ACCOMPIED BY BLOATIN
THAT YOU GET TO DECIDE.
HERE ISNOTH PIECE OF TAPE
THAT @LibsofTikTok UARTHED,
A TEACR SCREAMING AT A STUDENTFS
>> NO,'M NOT.
OTHEISE  WILL CALL TH
POLICE.
I'M SERUS.
>> A YOU SIOUS?
>> YH, I AM SERIOUS, M.
I' HAD ENOUGH OFHIS.
I KNEW YOUERE GOING T TAKE
OFF YOASK THE MOMENI
TURNEDHE CORNE
SONJOY BIA.
SIT WITH TSE MILITARY GUY ALL
DAYECAUSE YOU ARE PIECE OF
[BLEEP].>> Tucke I'MOING TO CALL
THE POLICE COM HE SCREECHESBECAK
NOW AGAIN, MAY YOU ARE OKAYWITHY
EMIONALLY INCOMPENT NUT
CAS LIKE THAT.
MAYBE YOU A N.
T YOU PROBABLY OUG TONOW
EITH WAY SO YOU CASEE WHY
@LibsofTikTok QUILY BECAME
SO VERY PULAR.
YO DO NOT HAVE TO WAIT F AN
EDITORL TO FIND OUT WHAT ISHAPPW
VIDEO AND AESSMT FOR
YOURSELF.
MIIONS OF PARENTARE GRATEFUL
FO THA.
SO I THE PRESSECRETARY FOR
THE GOVERNOOF FLORIDA,RON DeSAI.
ITAS PARTIALLY IN RESPONS TO
VIOS SHE SAW ON
@LibsofTikTok THATLORIDA
ULMATELY BANNED BLIC SCHOOLACHEG
KINDERGARTNE ABO SEX, ONE OF
THE MOST PULARAWS IN T
STATE.
THE MAJORITY OF DEMOCRATS
SUPPORD.
@LibfTikTok WAS GTING
RESUS ISOOD JOURNALISOES.
NOT D FOR A TWITTER FD.
SO OF COURSE TT WODF HE
THE BIDEN ADMISTRATION AND I
MANY SERCES IN THE NEWS MEDIA
T TO WORK.
MEDIA MATRS PUBLISHED FR
PIECESN @LibsofTikT INHE
ST FOUR WEEKS, IT WA
TRAFFIING,LLOWING LERALS
TO TK ABOUT THE SELVES, IT
WAS ANTI.
AUGH
ASF THE SITE WAS ATTKING
ANYBODY.
IT WAS NOT, JUST PLA TAPE OFPEO.
ENTIRELYWICEWTHE COUNT THIS,
THEYUSPENDED IT.
ONE OF THE SPENSIONSAME
AFTE A COMPLAINT FM A HARVARD
LAWNTRUCTURE, "MY REPOR ON @LibG
TI-TOC RULES GOT THE
SUSPENDECOME HERAGGED.
THPERSON WHO RUN
@LibsofTikk KT GOING.
ULMATELY JEFF BEZOS WEIED
IN, HIPERSONAL NEWSPAPER
"T WASHINGTON PO" DIDED TO
HARASS THEAMILY OF THE WOMAN
WH OPERATES @LiofTikTok.
EY CLD NOT FIND HER SOHEY
WE AFTER HER FAMY.
POST OF WHATT CAL I TECH
LUMNT TAYLOR THE RT TO
SH ALL OUTSIDE T HOM THAT
BENGS TO ONE OTHE MAN'SRELATIVE
AND THEORENZ S ABOUT
FINDG THE WOMAN HERSE, S
CODN'T,END A DIREC MESSAGE
SOMEONE ON TWTERHO TURNED
OUT TO NOTE THAT WOM IT HAD
NOTHING TO D WIT THE AOUNT
ATSOEVER BUT BAUSE SHE D
THATE KNOW WHAT TAYLO LORENZ
S SAYING, HERS WHAT SHE
SAID, "YOURE BEING IMPCATE
INTARTING A HAT CAMPAIGN
AGAINST LGBTQ PEOPLE.
RIT.
HATEAMPAIGN.
SO HER YOU HAVE TAYLO LORENZ
INTIMIDATE ARIVATE CITIZEN DEEPO
INTO SILENCE.
ANDHIS MORNING SHE GAVE IT
HER BEST SHOT.
"THE WASHITON ST" PUBLISHED
A PIECE B LORENZ LINKI TO THE
NAME, THE PHYSIL ADDRESS, AND
E REAL ESTATE CENSG
INFORMATIONF THE WOM WHO
RUNS @LibsofTikT
AFTE THE PT PUBLISHED THE
@LibsofTikTok NT INTO
DING.
TH WAS OF COURSEHE WHOLE
KNOW WHERE SHEIVES BECAUSEE
"THE WASHINGN POST" LINKED TO
IT SOHE H TO LEAVE.
NOWAYLOR LORENZF ALL PEOPL
KN THIS WOULD HAPPEN, SHE KNEW
WHAT SHE W DOING WHEN SWROTE TH.
SHE WAS TING TO SHUT THIS
WOMAN UP.IT WAS JUS A COUPLE MOZ
HERSELCOMPLAINED ON TELEVION
THAT SHE WAS BEING HARSED AND
TH NONE UNDER ANY
CIRCUMSTANCEWOULD BE AOWED
TO SW UPT HER HOME.
HE OR SHE IS.
>> TROS LIVE EVERYWHERE.
N YO DRAW A PICTU OF WHAT
IS LIKE WHEN A SURGE OF
HARAMENT HITS?>> IT ISORRIFYINGS
NOT JUST ME, EITHER,HEY
IMMEATELY DOCS YOU ANDO
TER UR FAMILY MEMBERS,HEY
TRY D LOOK UPVERYE WHO HASEVER .
COMPLELY ORWHELMING AND
TEIFYI.
>> Tucr: OH, THEY G AFT
YOUR FAMY MEMBERS!CAN WE PUT TTE
THEAMILY MEMBERS  THE
WOMAN WH RUNS @LibsofkTok
THOTHER D.
HARAING THE FAMILY MEMBERS.
THTAPEOU JUS SAW COMES FRO
JAARY.
AGO, TAYLOR LORENZ W CANNOT
ST TALKING ABOUTERSELF,
OWNING IN LE ME, CRIED O
TELEVISION BAUSE SHE HAD BEEN
CRITICIZED OINE.WATCH.
>>'VE H TO REMOVE EVE
NGLE SOCIAL TIME, I HEVER
PT FROM TS FR OI
NTEMPLATED SUICIDE.
IT G REAY BAD.
YOUEEL LE ANY LITTLE PIECE
OF INFORMAON THAT GETS O ON
YOWILL BE USED BY TH WOR
OPLE ON THE INTERNETO
STROYOUR LIFE.
AND IT IS SO ILATING.
D TERRIFYING.
IT ISORRIFYING.
I'M  SORRY
>> THAT'S FIN
>> IT'SVERWHELMING.
IT'SEALLY HARD.
>> Tucker: IS REALL HARD TO
WORK FOR "THE WASHINGT POS"
'S HARD, NO PER.
IF Y REALLY THI IT IS HARD
AND YOU ARE AINSTHAT KD OF
HAVIOR, WHY ARE YOU ENGAGINIT A?
A FEW WEEKS LAT, AFTER
SHOOTING THATERFORMANCE,
TAYLOR LOREN SHOWS U AT THE
DOOR, THERIS THEICTUIGHT
THER COME OF A RELIVE  THE
PRIVATE CIZEN WHOOSTS VIDEOS
AT TAYLOR LORE'S BOSSES
DON'T LIKE ANDHEN SHE POSES POST
RSONS IDENTIT ONLINE.
TH IS A CAMPAN TO SHUT DOWN
THE TWITTER FE.
DIGG O STEP DEEPEINTO THE
ORY AND ASK YOURSEL DID
TAYL LORENZ, THE WOMAN Y
ST SAW HER CRYING  TV, DID
E DOHE REPORTING HERE?
D SHE RLLYRACK DOWN THE
PERSONAL INFORMATIONF T
WOMA WHO RUNS @bsofkTok?
PLEASE.
OF COURSE NOT.
E COULD E.
TAYLOR LORENZS NOT AEPORTER.
APART OM WHINING ABOUT HERSEON N
SHE IS MEREL A RECEPTACLE FOR
INFORMATION OTH PEOPLE GATHEFORD
SOHERE DID SHE GET THI
INFORMION?
WHO GAV HER T IDENTIT OF THEWOM?
ACTUAL, W DON'T HAVE TO GUESS
BECAUSE "THE WAINGTON POST"
ANSWERS THAT QUESTION.
"T POST" PIECE TELLS UTHAT
FORMATION CAM FROM A M
CAED TRAVIS BRO.
TRAVISROWN RUNSTRAV BROWN
HATE SPEEC TRACKER WHI USESA VAS
TO REVEAL PERSONALLYDENTIFYING
INFORMION OF PRITE CITIZENS
WHO STRAY OM THE APPROVE
STORY NE.
NOW O PAYSOR ALLF THIS?
THAT IS THE QUESTION.
WELL THE TRAVIS BRN HATESPEECH D
SOMETHING LLEDHE PROTOTYPE
FUND.
HERE IS TH PROTYPE FUND
DERIBES THE POINT OF TRAVIS
BROWS PROJECT
"PMINENT RIGHT WINGXTREMIST
ACCOT ON TWITTER AND FACEBOOK
HAVEEVELED A WELL-DOCUNTED
PATTN TO DISIBUTE ORIGINA
AND EXTREMIST CTENTO DERICK
BOWERS A THEN -- ARCVING IS
AN IMPTANT FACTOR, LED TOPROMINT
AGAINS T SUPREME EXTRE
RIT.EXTREME GHT, SO NOTLL HATE
SPEECHS THE SAME, AND HATE
SPEECH TRAER DS NOT TGET
ADMINISTRATIONND THE GUYS AN
DA'S.
HOW DO THE DO IT?
BROWN'S METHODS INCLU
TOMATED SOFTWARE TO SE USE
ACCOUNNAMES AND SOCL MEA
POST LON AFTER THEY HA BEE
DETED SO THERE IS N HIDING
OM THESE PEOPLE.
THAT APPEA TO BA VIOLATION
OF TWITTER'S TERMS OF SERVICE
T THAT WE CARE BECAUSE THE
N'T CARE, WE REACH OUTO
TWITTER ABOUT THIS, ISN THIS A
VIOLATIO[LAUGHS]
THEY IGNOR US TO.
EY SUSPENDED O ACCNT.
WHATSNTERESTING IS TRAVIS
BROWHIMSELF APPEA TOE A
FORMER TWITTER EMPYEE.
SO AGA, WHO IS PAYI FORH
THIS
WELL, A FOREIGN GOVERNMENT I
PAYING FOR I
E PROTOTYPE FUND GETS ITS
NEY NOT FROM PVATE DONORS
T FROM THE GOVERNMT OF
GERMY.
GERMY'S FEDERAL MISTR OF
EDUCATION.
IT SAYS SO RIGHT ON THEEBSITE.
IN OTHER WOR, WHAT HPENED TO
THEOMAN WHO RUNS
@LsofTikTok, HER LE BNG
DESTROYED, WAS NOTHE WORK OFTAYM
HER PTSD, NO, IT W A FOREIGN
INTELLIGENCE OPERATIONESIGNED
TO SILENCENDNTIMIDATEAMERICAN C.
WA, IS THAT LAL?
DI THEIDEN ADMINISTRATIO
HAVE ANY ROLE I THIS PARTICAR
INTEL OP?
WHY IS THE GERN GOVERNMTTRYING N
TWITTER ACCNT BOASTING ABT
AMERIC TEACHERS
AND SINCE S WAS TILLING
RECIPIENT OFHIS INFORMAON
FROM AOREIGN GERNMENT
SIGNED TO DESTR AN AMERICA
CIZEN, WHY DOESN'T TAYR
LORENZ ATHEERY LEASTREGISTER UN?
WE SEEM TO REMBER ITE A BITOF TS
FE YEARS, WEHINK THERE WAS AN
IMPEACHMENTRIAL OVER IT,SOMEONE.
BU TAYLOORENZ CAN TE
INFORMION FROM A FORGN
GOVERNNT TO CRU ANMERICAN
CITIZEN IS CLEAR PART OF AN
INL OPERATION AND SHE IA
JONALIST IN GOOD STAING,
JEFF BEZ